and the Oscar goes to
everything everywhere
all at once
we wear
seven Oscars tonight for after in a
supporting role actress in a supporting
role original screenplay film editing
directing actors in a leading role and
best picture
thank you
there is no movie without our brilliant
and big-hearted cast and crew Daniels I
don't know what to say I love you guys
you just won best picture
hey
um we've said enough tonight I just want
to say that thank you so much to
everyone here you have all inspired me I
think one of the things that I realized
growing up was that one of the best
things we can do for each other is
shelter each other from the chaos of
this crazy world we live in um have a
great night guys thank you so much thank
you everyone have a good night